welcome back to New rockstars I'm
Whitney van landingham and it's time to
grab a Corona say grace at a barbecue
and fast tenure seat belts because fast
X is finally here we've got a lot to
talk about from the latest Fast and
Furious film including brand new
characters throwback plot lines and
about a zillion lingering questions
after that Cliffhanger of an ending so
today I'm picking you frame by frame
through fast decks to cover all the
details you might have missed this is
your spoiler warning the movie opens up
with a flashback to 10 years ago during
the events of Fast Five at a police
station Rio de Janeiro the base of
operations for drug lord Hernan reyes's
criminal Empire at the end of Fast Five
the fast family robs Reyes of millions
of dollars by yanking a vault of his
money straight out of the wall of his
corrupt police station in fast X we see
the other side of the family's greatest
Heist from the perspective of Reyes in
his flamboyant knife-looking stun Dante
Reyes tasks Dante with capturing Dom and
the crew imparting with him the Reyes
family motto when suffering is owed
death is never payment in the background
of this scene you can can see ames's
back behind Reyes foreshadowing his rise
to power as Dante's Ally but after Dom
starts sewing in the Valk around the
freeway like a deathly yo-yo Dante and
Reyes are struck and Dante falls in the
drink while his near-death experience
and skull fractured didn't exactly knock
some manners into Dante he was always
dangerous with this opening scene
stating that he's plucked the eyes and
tongues out of those who have crossed
him in the present day Dom teaches
Little Brian to Tokyo Drift and bust
Donuts on the roof of a parking
structure in Angelino Heights
overlooking LA's City skyline these two
opening scenes a heist followed by a guy
named Brian doing donuts in a parking
lot with the skyline in the background
near the first two scenes of the first
fast and furious back at the family
barbecue at the Toretto home great
grandma Abuelita serves up her famous
Maduros AKA fried sweet plantains and
his low-key dressed like Elvis Presley
we know she's family because she drinks
Corona the established beer of the
Toretto family as revealed in the first
fast and furious also Roman takes the
first bite while Abuelita is giving
Grace breaking the spirit of the house
rule established in Furious 6.
hmm well first bite he's got Grace house
rules man house rules pege makes Hana
Tinder account to get him back out there
it's been years since Giselle died in
Fast and Furious four and he wants his
homie to find someone hot and special
adorably we also hear Brian call Letty
mom for the first time in this scene for
knowing how much John loves family I'm
sure that little B knows all about his
biological mom Elena too in Dom's garage
Han tells Dom we've come a long way from
the two of us popping gas trucks in the
Dr and the two of them clean Coronas and
say Los Bandoleros for life this is a
nod to the 2009 fast companion short
titled Los Bandoleros in which Dom
recruits Han for a heist to steal
gasoline for the local townspeople
behind Dom you can see a box with the
logo of teja's Auto Service AKA tej's
second garage that he opened at the end
of Fast Five the camera pans over old
photos pin to Dom's bulletin board
including one of Mia behind the wheel
from her first date with Brian Brian and
Dom working together on an engine when
they reconciled their friendship in the
fourth movie Han drinking at the family
dinner in Furious 6 Persian Roman at the
end of Fast Five as they boast about
their New Wealth Brian and Roman in
Miami from too fast Dom driving Letty to
drag her memory in the seventh film
Brahman dressy teaching Brian about cars
in the first film and finally Dom and
Brian with their signature cars at the
end of fast 7. this board also has a pit
pass from Dom's Childhood Days servicing
his dad's car and a couple pink slips
presumably from carsey's one in street
races during this little trip down
memory lane the instrumental version of
See You Again by Wiz Khalifa and Charlie
puth plays in the background aka the
song that was commissioned in memory of
Paul Walker for furious 7. in the other
room Letty and Dom are about to Bone
down when Brown tells Letty he's afraid
of losing a wife or a son Letty replies
that's not gonna happen again calling
back to her fake out death and
subsequent Amnesia from Fast and Furious
4 and Fast and Furious 6. We also get a
pan over to a photo of their wedding in
Furious 7. Cipher a woman who until now
has never had a good haircut and The
Mastermind from fate of the Furious and
F9 shows up bloody on Dom's doorstep she
reveals that Dante approached her for
help Stoller Tech and is planning to use
it to make the family suffer after Dom
has her taken to a black site prison by
the agency he finds out that Roman tej
Ramsey and Han were sent on a mission in
Rome as a trap in Rome tej wears a two
thousand dollars off-white brand
letterman jacket Roman drives a gold
Lamborghini Gallardo and Han drives an
orange and black Alpha Romeo keeping to
his recurring color theme set by the
1997 Mazda RX-7 he raced back in Tokyo
Drift when Ramsay Surprises tej with her
car knowledge she replies that she knows
stuff now a call back to the fact that
she didn't even have a driver's license
when we last saw her in F9 Roman reveals
that he's included an RC car with a
model of tiny tej on top as it zooms
down the street it repeats his most
famous line from 2 Fast 2 Furious all
right all right all right fire em up and
this is where Dante comes in after
stealing Cipher's Tech Dante plants
explosive devices underneath the
family's cars and tejan Ramsay realize
that they're driving a bomb the size of
a Tiny Death Star that's about to blow
in the back seat of the van they just
stole and Mr nobody's former right-hand
man little nobody from fate of the
Furious says he's gonna try to disarm
the bomb before it blows up the Vatican
grante intercepts their walkie-talkie
conversation saying sorry Captain
America can't let you do that the MCU
exists in the f see you baby kind of
wild considering that the mainstream
superhero roster crossover in this
franchise is massive in this universe
Groot was raised by yondu to become a
street racer that would befriend Wonder
Woman Captain Marvel and Black Adam the
latter of which spun off to team up with
Hesperus son in order to fight Heimdall
based on Intel from Deadpool by the end
of this franchise Groot will probably
have to find a way to kill klia DCU
Aquaman and Smallville Aquaman with a
car down is able to close line Dante's
truck causing it to flip similarly to
the armored trucks in F9 unfortunately
Dante is able to get the bomb rolling
and Dom has to channel his best rocket
League skills to save the people and
dogs of Rome from being crushed Dante
himself notes that this is a bit of an
homage to the wrecking ball Vault Dom
used in Rio Dominic manages to knock the
bomb into the water by launching his car
onto a crane it still causes major
damage in Rome and Dante basks in the
explosion in a Christ pose despite being
a self-described devil Dante leaks ever
everyone in the family's names to an
international most wanted list several
major news outlets cover their alleged
criminal activity including NBC and news
9. ladies arrested and taken back to the
same black site prison as Cipher and
Ramsey Pez Roman and Han escaped through
the Roman sewers the agency turns on the
family and their barbecue hating leader
Ames describes Dom's crew as a cult with
cars saying that he has to take them out
because if it violates the laws of God
and gravity they've done it twice
clearly referencing their ridiculous car
trips rocketing to the Moon parachuting
from airplanes Tarzan swinging and
jumping through multiple high-rise
buildings we made this video with the
help of geology and with their help you
can make your skin healthier than ever
geology is a 22-time award-winning skin
hair and body care company recognized in
men's health Oprah daily hypebeast
birdie Esquire and GQ their products are
built around just a handful of powerful
proven ingredients that have been
trusted by dermatologists for decades
just take a quick 30 second diagnostic
quiz and geology will create a simple
and effective skin care or hair care
routine customized just for you
geology's co-wash and deodorant are
great and I use them all the time but
right now they're running a special
offer for a skin care sampler Pat and
geology skincare stuff is in a league of
its sound geology's line of skincare
products can help you fight acne reduce
oiliness prevent wrinkles combat dark or
puffy under eyes have smoother hydrated
skin and Target signs of aging there's
never been a better time to try geology
than right now for a very limited time
use code rockstars 100 to get 100 off of
your personalized 30 day skincare sample
set all you have to do is cover the 495
for shipping on top of that new
rockstars fans get an exclusive bonus
offer of up to 50 off on an additional
skin hair and body product of your
choice when you add it to your trial
click the link in the description or go
to
geolog.i.e rockstars100 to get started
Dom stands in front of the Coliseum
before meeting with Queenie Shaw in Rome
where he quotes Saint venerable Bay day
an English Benedictine monk from the
Middle Ages when he Muses when Rome
Falls so will the world I had no idea
that Dominic Toretto was a literary
scholar but this proves that this man
truly can do anything Queenie mentions
Roman Holiday a rom-com from the 50s
starring Audrey Hepburn and Gregory Peck
Dom asks Queenie to get a message to Mr
Nobody confirming that he is still alive
and that his off-screen death in fast 9
really was a fake out aim six the agency
on Mia Brian Little Brian and Abuelita
and several henchmen attacked the
Toretto home where Mia and Brian are
playing Hot Wheels Unleashed when Mia
accuses little B of cheating at the game
he quotes his father from the first film
it don't matter if you win by an inch or
a mile winnings winning luckily Jacob
shows up to help fend off the agency's
troops and slams one of the agents
through the floor with John Cena's
classic wrestling move the attitude
adjustment while Mia goes to alert big
Brian her kids and the others to get to
the Rendezvous Point Jacob and Little
Brian hop in the same 1992 Ford Mustang
he raced Domin as a teen as they drive
from La towards Yuma International
Airport in Arizona Jacob introduces
Little Brian to Marky Mark and the Funky
bunches Good Vibrations and even
references Mark Wahlberg's careers and
underwear model at the airport they run
into cameos by actress Debbie Ryan and
her husband Josh Dunn of 21 Pilots
reportedly repair big fast fans even
including a nod to the franchise in
their wedding vows Tess finds Dom at a
bar in Naples Italy where she reveals
that she stole God's eye from the agency
a software invented by Ramsay back in
Furious 7 and tells him that Dante
pinged from a location in Rio when she
arrives to kick ass and drink beer she's
wearing a jacket with the words Good
Vibes only on the back during their
conversation Hess jokingly refers to
Dom's Rio Heist by saying that she
doesn't trust vaults people can just
pull him straight out of walls she also
confirms that her father is missing
rather than dead so we'll definitely see
him pop up in one of the next two movies
Dom asks Tess to get Letty out of prison
and she sets a plan in motion to free
her when Tess meets Letty in the black
site prison and she wins her trust by
talking about her scars this is the same
way that Dom started to earn her trust
back in Furious 6 back when she had
Amnesia in Rio Dom is greeted by Diogo a
Brazilian street racer that we met back
in Fast Five Isabel Dom's baby mama and
Elena's sister and a bunch of girls
shaking their butts as Dom Diego Dante
and Isabelle line up to race a remix of
Daddy Yankee's Gasolina plays because
it's just not a fast and furious movie
without butts and Gasolina as the racers
pull up to the starting line the camera
work mirrors the street racing 2 Fast 2
Furious sadly Dante seemingly kills
Diogo with an explosive during the race
but who knows anybody's fair game to
come back to life in these movies Tom
manages to save Isabelle and back home
she laments that she a street racer had
nothing in common with her sister a cop
Dominic tells her that in his experience
cops and Street Racers can learn to get
along a nod to the Brotherhood he formed
with Brian actually toretto's crew has
quite the track record of turning law
enforcement into family Dom and Brian
Brian and agent Monica Fuentes from 2
Fast 2 Furious Brian and agent stasiak
in fast six Dom and Mr Nobody Diamond
Hobbs Etc after playing nail salon with
a couple of corpses in his backyard
Dante hacks into the family's bank
accounts stealing their money and
redistributing it to mercenaries
worldwide fortunately Roman is a little
freak and has strapped his entire body
with fat stacks of cash kinda like he
did with the money he stole at the end
of 2 Fast 2 Furious Ramsay takes the
guys to a cyber cafe run by Pete
Davidson who goes by the hacker named
Bully 420 in honor of David Bowie and
everyone's favorite Stoner holiday
Ramsay herself apparently used to go by
Freddie Merc the deadlier version of
Freddie Mercury tej calls Roman Bezos
because both men have all the money and
have been to outer space also I'm gonna
need help on this one but is anyone else
utterly confused by Roman tossing white
dust in this scene is this magician
glitter is he using cocaine as pocket
sand at the black site prison Letty
awakens next to Cipher who knocks out
the guards and tries to help Letty
Escape Letty obviously decides to kick
her ass for being the Mastermind behind
most of the family's hardships over the
last several movies but when she
shimmies up a shaft to escape a few
scenes later she learns the hard way
that they're being kept in Antarctica
Cipher hands through a snow suit and the
two of them make their way across the
frozen tundra where they're met by
Giselle who surprise isn't actually dead
she's driving a submarine beneath the
ice a nod to the submarine from fate
damn she's gonna be pissed when she
finds out that Han made a Tinder right
before she came back to life back in Rio
Isabelle finds Elena's old police files
on Dante who has a long record of
psychiatric hospital stays and jail time
on his resume believing that he'll find
answers at the old police station where
he and Brian stole the Vault all those
years ago he heads over instead he finds
a dark room filled with TV screens each
featuring a slideshow of Dom's Family
Photos including the seen from the
beginning of F9 were Ramsay tej and
Roman show up at Dom Letty and little
Brian's home Off the Grid baby photos of
Little B Mia and B running out of the
Toretto house after the attack a photo
of the whole crew including big Brian
and Dom and letty's wedding photo Dante
also replays images from the day his
father was killed on the bridge in Fast
Five after calling Dom on a pink rotary
phone to threaten him Dante has him
arrested by the agency Jacob and Little
Brian have tried to blend in by wearing
clothes they bought at a gas station and
carrying what looks like a giant kayak
obviously they're spotted so Jacob gets
three mini bottles of Smirnoff vodka
from the flight attendant the flight
attendant is actually a cameo she's
played by Paul Walker's daughter meadow
walker next Jacob and Brian jump from
the plane and what I can only describe
as a sky kayak a kayak if you will and
land safely in Portugal picking up where
the mid-credits scene at the end of fast
nine left off Han Ramsey tejan Roman
arrive at Shaw's place where he's beaten
up some poor bastard inside of a
punching bag although Shaw initially
things Han is there to enact his revenge
on Shaw for killing him at fast six AKA
after the events of Tokyo Drift
according to the FCU timeline he quickly
realizes that the agency is attacking
all of them and helps the rest of the
crew fight back finally calling his beef
with Han even don't know how to drive
what do you think when Ramsay pulls up
her computer to show Dante's next
targets we see images of Sean Boswell
from Tokyo Drift agent Fuentes from 2
Fast 2 Furious Queenie Shaw buddy from
F9 and Tega Leo Enrico Santos from The
Fast and the Furious one Jaws safe house
also houses some notable cars from his
family's past there's his McLaren 720s
from Hobbs and Shaw and his brother's
ramp car back in Rio Dante lures the
Convoy transporting Dom to the same
bridge where his father was killed years
ago when Tess shows up Dante asks Dom if
he likes ballet saying that he adores
Swan Lake while Dom seems like more of a
nutcracker guy a version of
Tchaikovsky's Swan Lake begins to play
in the background as Dante shoots Tess
steals God's eye from her and heads off
to find Little Brian over in Portugal
Jacob and Little Brian are waiting for
the rest of the family to arrive at
Jacob's tunneled safe house when Dante's
mercenaries arrive they bust out in
Jacob's custom-built Cannon car and
honestly Little Brian expresses way too
much joy when he murders like 10 grown
men with families using the Canon
launcher the brief shot of Jacob pulling
out of the safe House's cave is intended
to be reminiscent of the cave race in
the fourth film sadly after Dom catches
up Jacob makes the choice to sacrifice
himself to save his brother and nephew
and uses his cool ass car to blow up
more of Dante's henchmen and look here's
the thing about Jacob's death as usual I
want to say that nobody ever really dies
in The Fast and the Furious but were two
movies from the end and they needed to
have a big impactful death in this movie
to solidify Dante as a three film
villain so maybe Jacob really is dead or
maybe he'll come back for the family
barbecue at the end of fast 12 who knows
as he does with the vault in Fast Five
Dominic once again proves that you
should never attach anything to his car
by taking down two helicopters at once
he's also bringing together his Highway
jump from six and his tow cable immunity
from the fate of the furious Dom rescues
Little Brian from Dante's clutches by
having bleep from Dante's open car door
into Doms a rescue move we've seen
executed in previous fast films they
start heading over a damn Bridge towards
the Airfield but surprise again Ames
reveals that he was a bad guy the whole
time obviously we all saw this coming
because no one who hates barbecues could
ever be a part of this family Dante also
has Roman tej Han Ramsay and Shaw's
plane shot into the side of the
mountains and Dom has no choice but to
smash some more trucks and drive his
flame engulfed 1970s Dodge Charger
straight down the dams nearly vertical
wall and a cliffhanger ending the likes
of which we haven't seen since The
Empire Strikes Back Bronte arms a bomb
on the side of the dam that threatens to
blow the whole thing crushing or
drowning the Toretto boys but I still
have so many unanswered questions did
the rest of the family survive of the
plane crash how is Gisele still alive
and when did she start working with
Cipher or big Brian and the kids also
technically supposed to meet at the
Rendezvous point and if so where are
they you can't keep giving Paul Walker's
character things to do in these movies
without bringing him back to lifeable
tests and Isabel leave the hospital in
time to help the family I need to know
these things we do get a hint about
where Dante might be headed next on his
Rampage of suffering and destruction
when Luke Hobbs pops up in the
mid-credits scene after stumbling upon a
TV playing a video of Roy Rogers and
Dale Evans singing Happy Trails he like
Dom also finds a room filled with TVs
showcasing his private photos Dante
calls him with a warning that because
Hobbes fired the bullet that killed his
father he'll be after his family next
but as always Hobbs delivers a cool
one-liner to close out the movie well I
know I'd find you some [__] follow me
on Instagram and Twitter whitneypuppy
Fallen new Rockstar subscribe to me
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love and thanks for
watching bye
[Music]
foreign